Full time.
No,
no,
no.
Like battlefield earth there,
you know?
Yeah,
you're,
you're fucking that fucking
Trump gave NASA a whole shit load of money in like $19 billion and said,
okay,
here's the money,
but we're going to fucking know.
Let's go to the moon.
So they,
they started a campaign to go to the moon and they just canceled the mission.
Why?
Oh No,
no,
no.
They didn't cancel the mission.
They canceled the Moon Rover cancels.
I'm talking about as a camp.
They canceled the,
the construction of the moon and everybody's confused.
They don't know how they did that because this is like the last moon rover that
they,
unless they have some new top secret moon rover that they won't,
don't want to let anybody know about it.
Maybe they found some new cool shift maybe.
Probably.
Yeah.
Maybe they can't go.
If we really did match up,
said,
let's go.
And I'm like,
okay,
give us the money.
Let's figure it out.
Okay,
we'll figure it out.
We've got 19 billion.
Imagine if we really didn't find out.
Nobody else is working on it.
Putting a on the rover on the moon,
but and the,
and the NASA wasn't either until Trump said,
here's the money,
let's go to the fucking moon.
And then we're going to Mars.
She matched.
If Trump goes on TV and says,
there's lot of things talk about,
one of them is it's terrible tragedy.
We've never been to the moon,
ladies and gentlemen.
That's some shit he would do.
Yeah,
he doesn't know.
He doesn't know.
How do you know he doesn't let them know he's too busy with those friends with
Alex Challenge.
He's a legit crazy talk that much because he can't,
they can't.
Everywhere they go.
They're wearing wires.
Everyone's wearing a wire.
Their phones are being tapped.
Ain't on is Qa and heard about that.
It's crazy shit.
What is it?
Qa non is someone in the Trump administration but people think it's someone in
intelligence in the military who's dropping all these clues on four Chan and
eight Chan.
So the whole thing is,
is it real?
Is it disinflation if someone's playing a trick but it's he,
he legally can't say what's going on behind the scenes.
Another leg lock.
Look at this.
He legally can't say he's getting it because it's against the law.
So he,
he's dropping all these clues and it's a,
it's someone named Q Anan and it's been going on for about three months and
there's all these people in the underground.
Uh,
basically he's saying trust the president.
It's going to take a while to take down all these,
uh,
corrupt people at the top of the FBI and the Department of Justice and all the
shit.
We're going to take them down one by one.
So He's been dropping all these clues on how they're going to do it.
It's pretty interesting.
You listen to it every day has drops every day and it's,
it's like,
uh,
it gets addicting,
but you don't know if it's real or not.
Like is it,
is it disinformation?
It's called Q Anan and Pete,
he makes drops every day and leaves all these clues of what's going on behind
the scenes.
No one can trace back to find out who he is or anything like that.
No,
I think on four Chan or eight Chan,
isn't it?
Like,
if you can,
you can hackers know how to drop information information without being tracked.
Right.
For sure.
Is that,
that's what's going on on,
I know you have,
right?
Yeah.
There's a bunch of posts about it,
but who knows if it's real or not,
but,
but the people that,
I mean,
there's people who,
there's a guy named Jerome Corsi who works for Alex Jones,
who that's his job is to analyze what's all of these clues of what's going on,
what Trump is doing behind the scenes,
because he's got the media,
all the entire media,
Hollywood FBI.
And what they're finding out is they're finding text messages and emails going
back and forth,
uh,
between key people,
running the government colluding to destroy Trump.
That's what's going on.
So for sure,
it's a crazy shooting him around people that have been in politics forever,
they didn't think he was going to win.
So they did all this shit thinking Hillary was gonna win.
But now that he won,
they're going back and looking at all the text messages from all of these super
powerful people.
People are,
are,
are resigning.
It's crazy shit going on and most people don't know.
It's like game of Thrones for real.
You're not.
Game of Thrones has like 50 characters and it would take you about a month to to
to catch up on what's going on.
There's just so much going on.
That's what's going on.
There's a game of Thrones going on right now,
but the media is only going to tell you their side and then Qa non is dropping
the behind the scenes clues it was,
but it's pretty fascinating.
Arm Triangle here.
There's another hundred percent it's all standing on hundred percent it's over a
hundred percent of the camera.
Oh,
go back to the camera.
He's talking to him.
You should jump to full guard.
Why do you think this has definitely done?
It's so deep in,
the guy's not doing anything with his left hand while he wasn't,
if he just jumps forward.
There you go.
Okay.
It's over now.
It's no way.
No Way.
He's going to say no way.